.
- Déco
- C'était l'événement
scentifique le plus attendu
de l'année. L'enjeu était
- C'était l'événement
scentifique le plus attendu
de l'année. L'enjeu était
complet : le télescope spatial
James Webb, une merveille
de haute technologie, est
maintenant parti pour la gloire.
Le lancement avait lieu
ce matin, au centre spatial
de l'Europe, qui se trouve
en Guyane française, au no
Après 30 ans d'efforts et
d'innombrables défis techniques,
les responsables étaient
visiblement soulagés. a mis une
vingtaine de minutes à traverser
l'atmo avant de relâcher
le télescope. Au cours du
prochain mois, la NASA va
tes pour déployer l'écran
solaire du télescope, puis
son grson grson grson grand mir.
La période de rodage
des instrumenta
jusqu'au mois de juin.
Un des deux grands objectifs
de la  toutes
premières galaxies, il y a plus
de 13 milliards milliards milli.
L'autre objectif principal :
tenter de découvrir des traces
ne des nombreuses
exoplanètes découvertesces dern.
RENÉ DOYON, prof. titulaire,
Département de physique, UdeM
- Donc, on sait où pointer
le télescope, mais ce qu'on sait
ont-elles une atmosphère?
Et si c'est le cas, a-t-on
y a-t-il de l'eau? Y a-t-il
les molécules essentielles
pour y trouver d
- Le Canada a développé
deux des quatres
du télescope. Un projet long
et complexe qui in
son aboutissement.0 ans que
je travaille sur ce projet-là...
en fai canada y
travaille : l'Agence spatiale
canadienne, le conseil national
enne à Honeywell.
Le Canada était là aujourd'hui.
Et ça a été un moment
- On ignore pour l'instant
quelles seront les premiè
images prises par le télescope
au mois de juin prochain,
mais les respons
qu'elles seront spectaculaires.
Ici Normand Gro
Radio-Canada, M